[Music]
when louis st pierre and kathy brosmer
started dating six years ago
they weren't looking for love we were
very content individuals when we met it
developed very slowly actually it was
about three months i think before he
gave me a real kiss
years later they're happy and committed
even though they have different
interests
louis likes his woodworking shop
and kathy enjoys playing music
he likes his big screen tv
and she likes to read quietly
hey honey and there's something else
that makes their relationship different
from the norm
i've been in my house for almost 35
years
and i've got it just the way i love it
right
and when i met louie six years ago he
was in a house about a mile away we kind
of came up with this idea that hey
we don't have to live together
and then i think it became this ah-ha
thing that we can just keep on
living like this apart living apart
together
they've both been divorced before and
learned from previous relationships they
knew that as much as they cherish their
time together they also appreciate their
time
alone a growing number of canadians are
finding partners and deciding not to
live in the same space
you can have a very good relationship
and live apart there are alternatives to
that traditional living together it's
called living apart together or lat
louie and kathy are so committed to
their arrangement louis recently bought
the house next door to kathy in sault
ste marie ontario
i'm working on my dissertation and it
takes a lot of focus a lot of
concentration so sometimes in the
evenings i'm going to try and get
something done
now
more often than not i'll say you need to
go home because i can't focus with
distracting sounds and because he's
right next door it's really super easy
he can go home for a couple of hours and
then come back and give me a good night
kiss
according to statistics canada the
number of couples choosing a lat
lifestyle is growing between 2006 and
2017 the percentage of couples claiming
to be living apart together rose from
six to nine percent
[Music]
and it's not just canada at stockholm
university in sweden livia ola an
associate professor of family demography
studies what kind of people are drawn to
lat relationships
so this freedom and to make up their own
rules that's what appealed to many
people and it seems that it appears
especially to women and particularly for
single mothers
she also says it allows for more equity
in roles
breaking down stereotypes
they do not have to follow the usual
traditional gender roles
we mean doing what they used to do
household work and
other caring activities so therefore
this is appreciated by quite many
the largest group of canadian couples
living apart are 25 to 34 year olds
according to stats canada
in vancouver heather macdonald met her
partner when she was in her late 30s
they have been together now for more
than three years
the benefits to living apart together is
that you really make a point of spending
time with each other you're not going to
fight over the day-to-day your socks are
on the floor you didn't put the dishes
away
but you're gonna really enjoy each
other's company you just make a point of
every time you're together being special
because you don't have a lot of it
oh those are nice but i thought they
were blue
oh yeah those are different ones
she's also a single mother of a 14 year
old son and her partner jordan has sons
living at home as well
so we're really lucky because i live
right here and jordan lives about a
block away just over that way
i think one of my biggest concerns is
that i naturally take on a mother role
and my step kids have a mother and a
father they don't need a stepmom in the
background nagging them my job is to be
a support for them someone they can
trust
someone another positive adult in their
life and so by
not living together you avoid
the conflict of the day-to-day parenting
and you can just enjoy your the company
of your step kids
some might view this arrangement as
lacking in commitment but recently
heather and jordan publicly recognized
their devotion to each other
it was really important for me to have a
wedding you know when you don't live
together and you're not planning on
having children together
it was important for me to seal that
commitment
and have something that him when i
shared
libya says there are economic reasons
why some people are attracted to lat
like keeping assets separate
men who live in a lot relationship they
are more likely to own their housing
they used to think that maybe this is
the women that they are so much afraid
of losing what they have but here we
seem to have that actually lot men they
do not want to lose their apartment
either or their dwelling either
there are a lot of pluses to living
apart together but there are also some
downsides one of them is benefits and
we're not talking fringe
kathy isn't eligible for louie's
extended medical benefits and she feels
the current system is discriminatory
if we were living apart but married his
benefits would cover me and if we were
living together but unmarried his
benefits would cover me
in this case they don't just because
he's in the house next door
i can see it from the insurance
company's point of view that there could
be
more potential for fraud and that sort
of thing
but it's still
the only difference between a
cohabitating couple and us
is address we don't share an address and
to me that there's discrimination there
it's one of the reasons why the research
people like livia do is important it
seeks to understand why people choose to
live apart and for how long it gives
policymakers a better understanding of
what modern day relationships look like
and how to adapt
and the pandemic may be increasing the
number of people attracted to this kind
of lifestyle
natasha sharma is a relationship expert
why or how could living a part together
be good for our relationship we've been
in jail for two years
right i mean like we have
and
we've been seeing the same faces day in
and day out you know i'm a mother i'm a
wife i have two kids and i think a lot
of people will relate to
you can get too much of a good thing you
really can too much of anything
even a good thing is too much
some might question the commitment of
couples who are not together all the
time because it's not what society has
taught us
we've been raised and shaped in this
archetype
says this is wrong this is not normal
this is dangerous you know to the
relationship but um i think what we're
seeing is that the reality of humans and
how we
are
for the most part
may not fit that model at least not
100 of the time what we need to do is
step back from this indoctrination of
the way we think things should look they
shouldn't look any way they need to be
reflective of our individual needs and
our individual desires and our
individual lifestyles and personas
kathy says it gives her the freedom to
live her life her way
we might have been able to compromise
and do all that you need to do
and live together
and we would maybe still be happily
together now
but it would have had more tension
and louis is quick to point out that you
can't really judge the commitment in a
relationship on the basis of whether two
people live together or not
we're together because we really want to
be together
so i think that makes it better for us
because we want to be together and we
have a lot of fun together
as a consequence i think it's just a
better relationship
[Music]